you hear your phone you look down and
what do you see
incoming video call after you hit the
client think about how commonplace video
chats become for a long time the idea of
seeing someone from across the world was
only in science fiction so how did it go
from looking like this to this let's
find out how the science fiction
inspired science reality as
communication devices have dramatically
changed sci-fi has been a step ahead
imagining new devices and their effects
on society for better and for worse
[Music]
mobile phones and tablets appeared in
sci-fi years before we had them in real
life what we've wanted all along is
face-to-face contact through a device
telephone TV with callers able to see as
well as here
[Music]
at least since the invention of the
telephone
illustrator z' and authors envisioned
combining pictures with sound like
french author and illustrator george du
Maurier's telephone ESCO which looks
like a combination video phone and
flat-screen TV the videophone appeared
in the first episode of The Jetsons in
1962 when Jane Jetson had a chat with
her mother various versions of video
chatting appeared in sci-fi TV and
movies during the 20th century yes what
is it
meanwhile 18 t's Bell Labs was
developing a real-life picture phone
[Music]
in April 1964 the picture-phone debuted
for public demonstration at the World's
Fair in New York two months later
service began with booths in Chicago New
York and Washington DC first lady of the
US Lady Bird Johnson made an early
picture phone call to dr. Elizabeth wood
of Bell Labs the system was impractical
for home use involving expensive
equipment and a hefty fee per minute
video chatting remained elusive for
three more decades until we had the
internet computers with cameras and the
software to make it work our
grandmothers
Skype software was introduced in 2003 an
apples FaceTime followed in 2010 we
finally achieved the dream of the
videophone now call your grandma she'd
love to see you
[Music]